the music started so let's see what kind
of rhythm you have
look at me I'm Superman
I ain't impressed somebody's
overcompensating anything I'm on the
comp insane
oh I can handle that
rated pg-13 you guys have to work
together no way unless champagne
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rated pg-13 I am bulletproof superhuman
things that money cannot buy I guess so
back your brother it's a boy so the boys
in the lab made me a new one black
Superman is good very good doesn't work
as a team
rated pg-13 I don't know my guy coming
in cars and guns
oh I can handle that part
if you're such a diva just be gonna be
hit the same that's it that's exactly
why I hate working with you mr. arson
here only knows how to blow things up
no offense she-hulk it only knows how to
smash
look at the two of you the fate of the
world is in your hands and you can't
even get along you think I'm stupid
of course I think you're stupid
[Applause]
like oh I got a mic on
rated pg-13 you think I don't think it's
our tracing paper
brushes so
like that no I got him I got a tiger
rated pg-13
you